es una novedad para un gobierno francés
en vísperas de su visita a córcega el
ministro del interior song cesc afirmó
que si el presidente manuel macrón gana
la reelección en abril estarán
dispuestos a discutir la autonomía de la
isla mediterránea la touring dijo se
podría ser el mismo modelo de autonomía
que en la polinesia francesa donde puede
seguir siendo parte de la república pero
se dejaría que gestione el aspecto
económico y social por sí mismo
económico y social buenas noticias para
algunos políticos destacados y por
supuesto estoy muy contento de escuchar
eso aunque todavía queda mucho trabajo
por hacer cubrir la oferta se produce en
medio de un recrudecimiento de la
violencia durante los últimos días más
de 100 personas incluidos casi 80
policías resultaron heridos en la ciudad
de bastia el domingo cuando estallaron
enfrentamientos en una manifestación en
apoyo a la figura nacionalista yvan
colonna colonna cumple cadena perpetua
por asesinar al mandatario de la isla en
1998 y es considerado como un mártir por
algunos independentistas corsos colom
fue atacado por su compañero de celda un
yihadista convicto el 2 de marzo y ha
estado en coma desde entonces mientras
que el gobierno asume parte de la culpa
prometiendo una investigación sobre las
circunstancias del ataque está pidiendo
calma antes de que los políticos puedan
sentarse a conversar durante décadas
varios grupos de córcega han exigido la
independencia o una mayor autonomía y
hasta hace poco sus demandas habían sido
ignoradas por parís como será esta
autonomía todavía está por definirse